[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John delone Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author and host of the Dr John deloney
show on the Ramsey networks is my
co-host today we talk about your life
and he does as well including
relationships and boundaries and family
and money and oh we're going to do it
all today and we're going to talk about
you right in front of you the phone
number is
88255 225 the advice is free and some
say it's worth what you pay for itle
5225 one week from yesterday John's new
book hits and that means you've got just
a couple of days to get the buying a
nonanxious life book building building a
buy buying the building i' like to buy
one buying the book building a non-
anxious life I'm trying to get all these
in one sentence here it's it's running
on and so there we go the book is coming
out and if you buy it on a pre-sale you
get $75 in free bonus items including
the ebook the audio book and one of
John's talks uh instant access to that
smoke fire and freedom that he did at
one of our smart conferences so jump in
and get all of that before the book
actually comes out next Tuesday you
don't want to miss this and um we are
seeing record numbers of these books
come out I was just in a marketing
meeting this morning here and it's uh
the number of you that are uh thinking
that he may have something to say
intelligent about this subject is
amazing because he does uh and the good
news about this it's not a psychology
book that uh will put you to sleep it's
actually on the Shelf where everyone can
reach it yeah that's important for me to
um you know we've we've got a world now
where Stanford Medical School professors
are able just to crank out a podcast and
talk to each other some really high
level stuff some amazing insights into
the human mind and I often leave some of
those exchanges like thinking two things
wow that's amazing and all right what do
I need to do right now right so and so
this book is I handed it to my my
13-year-old and said can you read this
go through it and he read it and he said
Dad I'll give you two stars and then he
then he laugh that's brutal um but it's
designed for everybody to be able to
access it and read it and then to more
importantly Implement a plan on how to
make your life better because um anxiety
is not the problem as it turns out it's
the alarm saying there's a problem right
and that problem might be that your body
is scann the environment recognized
you're lonely it might be that you have
tied yourself to a bank and they're
telling you what what to do tomorrow it
might be that your marriage is falling
apart it might be that you've been
trying to hold up the universe all by
yourself for a long long time and um
there's several things that will set
your alarm off and um we have an entire
world designed around the idea that the
problem's over there the problems over
there the problems over there and I'm
challenging people to go look in the
mirror and say what can I do right now
in my home or with my family with my
community and start making these things
better right now yeah wow wow good stuff
folks check it out go to Ramsey
solutions.com and get it while it's hot
building a non-anxious life $20 it's a
deal on a book today I was was looking
at some uh data the other day um our
publishing guys were bringing me the
average hardback book right now in
America is $32 really yeah wow I didn't
realize it had slipped up we haven't
raised our prices enough and well we
haven't our cost of goods has gone up
like 40% because paper's gone way up
yeah and uh and we haven't raised our
prices enough and that's why I was in
that meeting they're trying to show me
like you're we're being doofuses and so
we're going to fix that but uh not right
now right now you can get this for $20
so that's pretty cool not 32 if there
was coming out of another publisher out
of New York it'd be 32 right now that
that's what the deal is that's the
average price right now of a hardback
advice book uh so check it out the phone
number here is
88255 225 Autumn is in Denver hi Autumn
welcome to the Ramsey Show hi Dave and
John how are you doing today better than
we deserve what's
up so my husband and I have quite the
conundrum we've been together for 15
years uh married for almost 13 of those
we love each
very much and we'd love to stay married
but we feel like we've tried everything
when it comes to managing our finances
and we just can't seem to agree the last
step that we have not tried is divorcing
our finances so I'm calling to ask if we
should divorce our
finances what would that get
you well let me give you a little bit
more background so we met at 21 and 24
respectively and had equal amounts of
student loan debt so we both had about
20,000 each so we decided that easiest
thing to do would be combine our
finances We Were Young we didn't have
any assets so it just made sense so
however we both come from very different
financial backgrounds and I tend to be
on the offense and he tends to be on the
defense and we both feel like we're
pulling each other and dragging each
other Along on a path financially that
we don't want to be on he was pretty
steeped in fire the financial
Independence retire early movement and
would prefer to spend less and retire
very early uh he's 39 I'm 36 for
perspective uh he'd like to be retired
tomorrow if he could and I prefer a
slower burn I'd rather make smart
decisions found Investments and work
harder and earn more to achieve our
goals and Lead maybe a more comfortable
lifestyle so if he retired today what
would he do with the rest of his
life well the things that he enjoys he'd
probably still make money but that's
always the question that I have asked
he's built a life he doesn't
enjoy not necessarily he just doesn't
like to work
so let me just cut to it this ends in
Ash Autumn because y'all aren't dealing
with the core issue the core issue is
you're trying to live two independent
lives next to each other in the same
bed and until you decide on we want our
life to look like this and we're going
to reverse engineer it starting today to
build it together you're going to be
like Jim Halpert and Michael Scott
you're going to be co-managers of this
thing and then eventually it falls
completely
apart well we've made it work for the 15
years you know that we abely have and I
had a 1994 uh F-150 that I duct taped
and glued together and made work for a
lot longer than it should
have so you're saying there's not a
healthy way to divorce our finances and
stay married and I'm G to tell you the
the further along you go trying to
pretend that what what John's saying is
was when you agree on your spending and
saving goals you've agreed on your life
on your life and your values and you're
not in agreement on those things you
don't have a husband then you have a
roommate so we actually come up with a a
yearly budget an annual budget we do a p
if you want to do it go do it you call
Nast us we're not talking about budgets
we're talking
about your budget reflects unified
values and you don't have that you have
two independent people trying to live in
independent lives and call it something
that it's
not okay so you haven't seen I mean I
know there's other people out there that
have have separated their finances and
say it was the best thing you know
because oh Lord Jesus they they can
knock your lights out you called me and
asked me they can say everything that
they want great great what I'm telling
you is this isn't about money hear me
say that it's not about your money it's
not about your finances one of the key
things we learned in studying 10,000
millionaires was none of them said I
drug my spouse into this Kicking and
Screaming almost all of them said I had
a unified plan with my spouse that
caused us to be able to achieve these
goals you are dreaming this is not going
to happen it's bad relationally it's bad
mathematically it's bad financially
you're wrong don't do it this is the
ramsy
[Music]
show
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 2 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today John in quotes that's not
his real name in other words from
Louisville Kentucky not his real place
in quotes big secret call coming in so
John what's your question yes sir um
well about about two years ago I I won
one of those multi-state lottery
drawings with a group of co-workers and
uh I haven't told anyone uh besides my
wife and besides one sibling uh no one
knows and my my question for you um
after taxes it was about $22
million holy crap wow holy crap is the
of the century yeah how old are you it
was it was a lot uh I'm I'm edging up on
uh about 50 years old okay okay so and
so you haven't told anyone and I've got
some guesses but uh
why uh well the first thing I did when
when I found out that I won was was
research and it said you know that you
read all those one in five people lose
their uh lottery winnings or go bankrupt
within 10 years and one of the things
they all said was you tell too many
people and you get too many people at
your door asking for this that and the
other thing asking for handouts and
expecting you to pay for everything so
my wife and I made a conscious decision
just to kind of keep it under RS and
it's kind of we we've kept keeping it
under wraps um we haven't even told our
two teenage children M and now I know
that sounds strange um but we just don't
want them to grow up uh to be waiters
you know waiting for us to die so they
can get our
money you
know that's fantastic man yeah I love it
dad's been eating little rat poison
lately I probably hey I honestly uh
I I'll spend the rest of the day
imagining I'm you because this sounds
just like a fun thing to think about um
I don't think I would tell my teenage
kids either no I'm okay with that no I
there I I I want them to go figure out
what they want to do in life and get
going somebody and then I'll and then
I'll let them know yeah I'm not I'm not
going to keep it from them forever but
like you know our parents and stuff we
haven't told any of them um we had we
had another incident about a month after
we won the lottery um incident I I don't
want to call it
my wife's great uncle passed away
shortly thereafter and he didn't have
any kids and he was never married and he
left most of his inheritance to my wife
and her siblings so we've been able to
use that as like our cover story for
when we help people like I bought my mom
a roof I know really really nice of me
yeah but how you know when she says how
can you afford this I just say oh it's
great Uncle Bob's money mom he want he
wanted us to do this or you know Uncle
Bob's money at least twox now that's
great yeah and you can get you can get a
have you got a decent
car I you're going to love me Dave U my
house was paid off before I won this my
wife and I really have no desire to move
good uh we had just paid cash for two
Toyotas before we uh before we won this
and we still have them we're not looking
to upgrade anything because they're
perfectly fine cars so okay we uh we we
are you still working are you still
working I am still I am still working
that ridiculous no it's not no actually
that's why I'm there because I kind of
like my job good for you I think you
should keep working yeah it's going to
make you a better employee because when
have you gotten some great investment
advice I have yes good I have I have a
team as you can imagine okay with you
need a you need a team yeah it's not a
huge team it's just it's a group and
they're they're they're doing well so
far doing good job good okay I like
everything you're doing um and it's not
it's not anyone else's
business right that's what I hope and um
I don't think you're being like a Hermit
in a cave weird uniom weird or something
like that I think you're just being wise
because what you've what you've
discerned is that some of the people in
your life could not
handle the
equation correct that is an a Very uh
good assumption on your part yeah and
and so you're doing them a favor by not
putting the strain on them including
teenagers so the only thing I can get
close to is is that um by the time my
kids were teenagers we had begun
building substantial
wealth we had recovered from the
bankruptcy Rachel was born so by the
time Rachel's 16 it's you know 17 years
since the bankruptcy and we had you know
I was a multi-millionaire again okay we
could buy whatever car we wanted to buy
we could go on whatever vacation we
wanted to go on and it wouldn't affect
us we had good money okay uh but the
kids had no idea and our kids had a
double problem one is their dad's in the
spotlight and everybody knows us right
because we're known in the community um
and talks about money no duh a and if
they had that and they knew that we had
millions of dollarss as a teenager I
don't think they could have processed it
so they did not know they knew we were
okay with money they knew we live the
principles that we teach and we made
them live the principles that we teach
but they did not know X number of
dollars was the net worth right I only
disclosed that to them after they
graduated from college and I involved
their spouses because by that time two
of them were married and so I sat down
with three of my kids and two spouses
five of them and we started unpacking
what our estate plan looks like because
they're adults at that point and I told
them up front I said listen here's the
deal we don't own anything at our house
we're people of Faith so God owns a
bunch of stuff he's asked us to manage
more than you know and you're getting
ready to know now and you get to decide
how you're going to react to that are
you going to react and continue to be
productive and generous people or are
you going to be in using your words and
I'll never forget it a waiter right uh
because if you're a waiter you're not
going to get access to any of this we're
going to take it away from you because
God wants you to be productive he wants
you to be whole he wants you to be
excellent in the marketplace and he
doesn't want this to destroy you he
wants you to have the opportunity to
serve a lot of people with this wealth
including my grandkids to come and so as
for me in my house we serve the Lord and
it's not our money it's his we're
managing it for him and someday you will
take over the management but you will
not become the owner if you think you're
the owner you won't get to take over the
management and we that's how I unpacked
it and then when I unpacked it I was
really pleased that they weren't Freaks
and they've continued to live really
good adult lives and it it's not ruined
to them that their dad has you know Dad
and Mom have a bunch of money that they
manage you know so uh all that so I
think you could start to build some
lessons into your teenagers now so that
in five years when you have that
conversation they're ready to shoulder
the weight of it what do you think John
all right yeah I think you're going live
by example and I think you have a pretty
remarkable opportunity
to take your kids out when you are
having them out to dinner and
noticing a waiter that's struggling and
call the waiter over and be really kind
and then show your kids let's leave a
huge tip you want to do that and it
might be a hundred bucks which is
nothing of of what you got in the bank
but it's it's going to be a million
dollars to a teenager right and you can
slowly plant the seeds of this is what
generosity looks like and when they it's
it's kind of like those movies you get
to the end and it like the six sense
right and it goes and you realize oh no
I missed the whole story and now I have
the whole whole story one day when you
sit down and say hey I'm uh you know
that school that I paid for and you know
you and your wife are about to buy
house I'm going to pay for your mortgage
and here's actually what we're sitting
on and here's I I like who I'm honored
by who you have become they're going to
go oh man I picked up all these lessons
from my mom and my dad they're also
going to learn that money isn't what
makes it isn't your identity your
identity isn't being a great dad it's a
guy who still got up and went to work
it's a guy who still kept the same
Toyota that he'd already paid with cash
before like you're doing everything so
right so healthy it's amazing Health
yeah man good for you if you were if you
were hiding this cuz you were freaking
and you were weird I would call I would
I would call you out on it you're wise
you're wise I think in this case you're
wise my my sister called me the other
day and said what was your big splurge
and my answer was patio furniture I'm
not a big flashy guy I I I don't well I
I I think you need to increase gradually
the enjoyment of this
money not to not not in the name of the
secret not in the name of exposing the
secret but you need to increase the
enjoyment and you need to increase your
generosity Factor systematically you
need to say all right this year we're
going to spend $400,000 on this or that
create some neat memories with your kids
yeah do do some things intentionally
with this without just kind of roll
rolling up an extra million bucks into
the budget this year you don't have to
do that although you've got it but um
yeah wow congratulations brother it's a
very good healthy view this is the
Ramsey
[Music]
show if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free seey blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings go to blinds.com and
get up to 35% off that's blinds.com to
learn more rules and restrictions May
[Music]
apply
thanks for joining us America we're so
glad you're here Cole and Abby are with
us in the lobby of ramsy Solutions on
the debt free stage hey guys how are you
great excellent happy to be here honored
to have you where do you live uh we live
in Franklin Wisconsin which is about 15
minutes south of Milwaukee Milwaukee
Wisconsin I love it very welcome to
Nashville thank you good to have you
guys and how much debt have you two paid
off we paid off
$15,999 I love it how long did this take
34 months good for you and your range of
income during that time we started at
134 and ended at 173 very cool what do
youall do for a living I'm an
occupational therapist okay and I'm a
production manager at a cpg company okay
very cool good for you guys wow what
kind of debt was the
196,000 mostly student loans yeah we had
about 10 in credit cards about 23 in car
debt and the rest of it almost
$159,000 in student loan debt
wow how ironic that this Sunday student
loan payments start back but not for you
no
wayoo we know a lot of people that
didn't pay any during the forbearance I
think I can count on one hand including
us the number of people that continued
to pay and hammered out yeah we do too
why did you do that because I I we
sitting around here obviously we're
we're talking shop it's like just math
get people to do what you did why did
you do it why did you do it all your
friends didn't do it the government said
we got you and you knew they didn't like
why did y'all keep paying yeah we're uh
in our 30s we're old enough to know uh
you can't wait on the government uh but
the other thing is that we wanted to set
ourselves up for our future right
someone bought us Financial Peace
University for our wedding and we sat
down and talked about our wise um our
baby girl we have now two months 3 years
ago when we started you know she wasn't
in the picture but we knew one day she
would and we didn't want to try to be
Buy house and buying cars with cash and
funding her College while having the
student loan debt hang over our head and
me the nerd I did the math with the
interest before the forbearance it would
have been $1,000 a month for 21 years
for us to pay off the student loan debt
and that's not something either of us
wanted to sign up for
wow so how long y'all been married three
years this past June okay so you've been
doing this the whole time you've been
married yeah we got married in June and
then because of Co we had like our
reception in September so it was in that
uh September reception we' already been
married for 4 months when we got
Financial Peace University okay so
somebody gave you that as a gift for
your wedding Y and then you you went to
the class yeah it was virtual right yeah
but yes we did the class and um we I've
been listening to you for years before
that and we were davish and this is how
dumb I was Dave I thought that's a
really good plan for other people yeah
not for us and even going into the class
we thought well maybe we'll do it maybe
we won't after the first lesson or two
we were all in we figured if we're going
to do it we got to do it all the way 34
months later here we are we're on to
three we're down with three now we're on
to 3B so we're excited for what's next
even taking it virtually it sucked you
into the Vortex oh yes it did I love it
well we're honored man congratulations
you guys what did your friends say when
you told them you're paying on your
loans and they they roll their eyes at
you yeah they did they give it to you
pretty good oh yeah um why would you do
that the same thing with the credit
cards um what about the miles what about
the points um you can use that money for
other things we just I don't know we
were just together in it the whole way
and that was a surprising piece actually
is how many people gave us schlack for
it um for having this be our plan so
that did that give you energy like I'll
show you yeah I I heard so many times
people say oh me and my wife are dead
free well except for our cars you'll
always have a car payment and we looked
at them and said then you're not debt
free uh we've heard you'll always have a
student loan and I look at him and say
you will always have a student loan we
will not always have a student loan uh
so it's very motivating yeah and now you
get to do Toby Keith How You Like Me Now
that's right that's right I like it yeah
you should throw a party on October 1st
just aay like I'll I'll get everybody
dinner cuz I know it's going to be a
hard hard night for my friend that's
right we got no we got no payment so we
can afford we're having a celebration
you guys are having a funeral guys that
uh we're hating on you that's right I
love it yeah just rub a little salt in
the wound that'd be great good for you
guys man I'm so proud of you thank you
so who was cheering you on who were your
cheerleaders a lot of our family
obviously my mother's side of the family
was the one who gifted us FPU so they
were huge in that um some of our friends
actually introduced us to you as well
and kind of kept along with us on the
journey that's cool yeah okay um yeah
that's about it our good friends uh
Britney and Sam I want to give them a
shout out because before we did this
we'd always go out on the town going out
to eat spending lots of money we told
them hey we're going to do this FPU
thing so we're not going out to eat
anymore and they said that's great you
guys just come on over here we'll grill
out we'll do things at the house that
are free they were very very supportive
like that that's a cool cool that's a
cool group of friends right there yeah
and actually you have a better time
doing that than you do going to R oh yes
yeah we had more yeah more fun yeah yeah
way to go guys so proud of y'all well
well done well done now what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt
you pay off
$196,000 in 34 months it's not a theory
you freaking did it m anyone can do it
on paper right it's a lot harder to do
in reality yeah um I always say the
hardest part is starting the first two
three months when you're learning to
budget and at the end of the month you
have this money it's it stinks to send
it off to Navy in or Toyota financial or
whoever but for us after those first 2 3
4 months it became such a routine and
such a habit it honestly went by really
quick just because we were like a
well-oiled machine once we got in the
monthly routine of budgeting and paying
off it became exciting actually how much
money are we going to pay off how much
how much are we going to be able to fill
in on our de turn into a game it's a
mental game like where where else can we
cut where else can we increase income
yeah yeah and every month we're like
yeah we're 150 bucks under budget let's
go like it's not that much but it's so
exciting um throw it at it throw y are
almost too unified did yall ever have a
fight we don't fight about money no no
no this um we were on the same page
pretty much before FPU but this really
solidified not just money but just all
aspects of our marriage I think yeah
what was the hardest
part I think getting started like Cole
said that is hard um but I also was
surprised I think I was disappointed by
people's reactions when we would tell
them that we were doing this saying no
telling each other no for things was
hard as well but just the reactions that
we would get this was such like an
exciting thing for us to start on and so
many people were doubtful or like that's
not going to last yeah um so that was
kind of hard to kind of hear that from
people well you kind of figure out who
your friends are yes you know it's like
okay you are
eore oh it's bad it's so bad you're
never going to make it you're always
going to have a car oh now I know who e
or is I always wondered who he is yeah
that's it so yeah good for you guys very
very well done hey we've got the live
and give bundle for you that's the box
that has all the goodies in it for you
to give away and live baby steps
Millionaire's book which is your next
step for sure The Total Money Makeover
book to give away maybe one of those
doubters or maybe one that needs to get
moving same thing Financial Peace
University membership for you to give
away and all of that's our gift to you
to say thanks for coming down all right
are we putting uh little baby in she's
ch right now but we can no you don't
have to I just ask that's that's a
sacred moment let it let it ride let it
ride if she if she's chill I'm good I
don't care I just didn't want you to I
don't want to lose you the opportunity
oh here she comes we'll just we'll leave
her in her little seat here all right
that's perfect yeah what's her name
Presley Presley all right Presley you
have no idea that your parents are
heroes they have changed your family
tree little girl yeah that's how old
Rachel was when I F bankruptcy so you
guys you guys are in a great place I'm
so proud of y'all congratulations thank
you very good all right Cole and Abby
Presley hold your little ears all right
196,000 paid off in 34 months making 134
to 173 count it down let's hear a
debt-free Scream 3 2 1 we're dead
free
yeah that's how that's
done ah I don't even think Presley woke
up that's pretty good I mean I think
she's used to her dad being that intense
around the house so it's all right it's
all good he's yelling at football too
that's exactly right he's more of a
spreadsheet Yeller but it's cool he
still
y loves works it works man I'll tell you
what if the first 34 months of your
marriage you can learn to uh align
yourselves together on goals you set
yourselves up to fight any battle to win
any game that you run into after that
don't you well it reminds us of that
call we took earlier this is what we
were talking about this is exactly
talking about you decide where you're
going getting there becomes just a it's
a totally different trajectory yep
you're not riding side by side you're
riding in the same car going to the same
place building the same life together
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian Healthcare Ministries a health
cost sharing Ministry but listen to
Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concerns about entrepreneurship
and motherhood was figuring out how to
take care of our health expenses but we
have found a solution that works for us
in an incredible way she loves that with
chm she can help other families who need
it and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
Dr John delone Ramsey personality number
one bestselling author and host of the
Dr John delone show is my co-host today
Travis is with us in Philadelphia hi
Travis welcome to the Ramsey Show
hello Dave how you doing better than I
deserve what's
up uh Dave I've been praying and this is
actually blessing speaking to you um
what's going on in my life around that
Dave is that me and my wife we at a
Crossroads we have two small children
we've been trying to do the baby steps
for almost eight months now it's it's
not working we're not we're not getting
past baby step one it's always some kind
of emergency things are happening that
and we're just not getting there um but
what we the crosss we're at right now is
that um I did get a we have a lot of
debt you have about $40,000 in auto
loans um about 10,000 student debt
student loan debt and 20,000 like credit
cards I have an offer to get a new job
that's gonna pay I pay I make about
37,000 now I got a job offer about like
54,000 it's not the best job in the
world just working a correctional offic
so it's something I'm not too fond of
but I'll do it uh for the money to get
out of debt but also we have a lot of
equity in our home uh our home is worth
about maybe upwards about 380,000 we
have about 230,000 left on the mortgage
and we can sell and we can get that
Equity wae you owe you owe 230 and it's
worth 280 380 no uh 38080 380 oh okay
yeah about 380 uh the real estate agent
say we should go uh probably should
price it at like 410 because it's things
are selling pretty fast in my area so so
you've got $150,000 you might have come
into if you did that if we did that
correct and where would you
live I live in Pennsylvania now we
moveed to I have a job offer in November
for the city of Dallas um for the police
department in Dallas and um that's
that's where we moved to we moved to
Dallas we have a have a good friend of
mine that lives out there he's been
working out there for about a year now
and he's been trying to get me to come
out there yeah and so we can move to you
have a solid written job offer not a
vague promise from a friend no I um I
have a solid written job offer in
November I will start the academy for
the police department out there I got it
and um okay so you were planning on
moving
anyway why would you ask me if you
should sell your house of course you're
going to sell your house you're moving
to
Dallas right but the reason why I I say
that because um like I said I have two
small children I'm just at a crossroad I
don't know if that's the best you know I
don't know how safe Dallas is I I have a
friend he said is is pretty good but you
know how safe Dallas is compared to
Philadelphia well I'm not I'm not
actually in Philly I'm about 90 minutes
away from it uh in the Pocono let me say
it this way my dad was a homicide
detective A Beat cop and then a homicide
detective for uh almost two decades in
Houston and he raised me and my two
siblings and I wouldn't trade my
childhood for
anything okay okay if you continue to
always look over the edge what if what
if what if what if in a weird way you're
going to create those scenarios in your
life right what would you pay what would
you be paid if you went to
Dallas um started salary for off out
there about 60 66,000 that's the solid
offer they gave you in
writing correct and then you get out of
the academy and then what does it go
to um that that I don't know but I know
going into the academy about 66 okay
okay so you're almost going to double
your income you're going to sell your
house move to Dallas and be debt free
and you've got no state income tax yeah
this is kind of a no-brainer Travis
you'll have no debt you need to put the
house on the market and go to Dallas and
you rent for a year in Dallas figure out
what's the best place for schools and
for that's going to fit your family's
lifestyle and what y'all are comfortable
with and then you're going to put an off
front house
yeah you're right it makes sense I was
just afraid of you know just moving to a
bigger city uh the crime the the you
know just just everything just wouldn't
be the best hey let me tell you
something turn the news
off you literally have a friend on the
ground who lives there and works there
and he says I love my friend I love you
enough you should come join me and
you're like uh I don't know because I
watch new your friend wouldn't tell you
come down here and get your children
killed
yeah you're right you're right okay so
move to Dallas Dallas is not a crime
ridden city it has crime every city has
crime but it's not crime ridden it's not
infested or something I don't this is an
IL an ill and you want to be a cop I was
going to say I mean this is kind of like
part of part of your there's a little
crime you wouldn't need a job part part
of the academy is going to be pushing
real hard to see risk ahead and go
anyway because that's what that's what
police officers do when the rest of us
are running they go in and so you're
going to have to you're going to have to
wash that part out of you man because
this is the job the the last thing I
want you to do though is when you clean
all this up you you guys have to get on
a budget and you have to quit freaking
spending money you don't have to buy
cars you can't afford in the future and
on these stupid butt credit cards so you
all have not been living on less than
you make you bought cars you couldn't
afford you bought other crap you
couldn't afford that's how these credit
cards got there so when you clean all
this up if you make 66 and you go to
spending 75 and you go upgrade your
dadgum cars and go back in debt well
then I'm going to come kick your butt
all right no you're not doing that all
right you're going to live on less than
you make you're going to clean this m
mess up this is your one time good time
reset you don't get to do these resets
very often yes yes so take advantage of
it dude jump online and get every dollar
the budgeting app you and your wife
start budgeting get the house on the
market find go to ramsy Solutions
and.com and get get one of the real
estate agents that are Ramsey trusted
and get your house on the market dad gum
man it's October you got to move in a
month get your button gear let's go
let's go let's go game on game on let's
you house ought to be on the market this
weekend you need to you need to go it's
time and you're going to be one of those
guys that's like well I need to clean it
I need to make sure that listen loading
up the truck and heading to Beverly baby
let's go sell the house sell the house
we're going let's go the gutters are how
the gutters are sell the house that's it
you know get out there and clean it up
this weekend get those kids and gear
trim the bushes mulch them let's go game
on game on I'm hearing this more and
more I hear this on my show with some
regularity and I think it's important to
Just note there's so many places to get
information these days that it does
overwhelm the Mind well and here's the
problem half of what is on the Internet
it's garbage is not even true 75% it's
not real it's not true I pulled up a
website yesterday with Ken and is on the
a mhm uh that's got Dave Ramsey's exotic
car collection and my picture and all of
the cars that I own only I don't own any
of them they're fabulous cars I wished I
did and I own a few nice cars it' been
cool if he'd put them on there but no
he's got all this wonderful vehicles on
there that I don't own that website does
not exist for me daude I I'm just like
Abraham Lincoln said everything on the
internet is true I mean come on you know
oh my gosh people yeah you just got you
got to quit just feeding garbage into
your brain and then cuz you know well I
read an article that said John deloney
or Dave Ramsey was this or that well you
can write an article on anything it
doesn't make it true people just make up
crap well that's why you know cuz
they're mad or their feelings are hurt
why it's important to have incredible
trustworthy men and women in your life
that you can call and say hey is this a
good deal and like man you're going to
love this job it's going to be great for
you and your family move on down here
yeah then that what that I I don't know
of a better endorsement that guy doing
that for Travis is a thousand out of a
thousand Travis reading about something
on the internet right is a thousand out
of a thousand the other
direction you know there there's crime
in Dallas well no of course there did
that I mean you know it's everywhere but
um at least in Dallas there's no anyway
yeah it's there's yeah do it Texas yeah
do it make Texas great again yeah let's
go game
on there's so many places I could go
with that in a minute and a half and I'm
not going to all right open phones here
atle 8825 5225 I should increase the
hate level around here I don't I don't
do that I think we're I think we are
good you think we got think the hate
level is high enough I think it is as
high as it needs to be okay I think we
should increase the love okay let's
increase the love okay well that that's
harder it is harder it is
harder sell your house man let's go d
Travis get that house on the market get
moved man send us a photo of you in your
uniform when you get out of the academy
we'll be rooting for you yeah you're on
our team man we love you keep it up get
after it get after it get after it that
puts this hour of the Ramsey Show in the
[Music]
[Applause]
books
hey it's Dr John deloney if you love the
show and want a deeper dive on your
money Journey we have a Weekly
Newsletter that gives you trending and
helpful articles and tips on following
the ramsy way just go to Ramsey
solutions.com today to sign up for our
newsletter again that's Ramy
solutions.com to sign up for our Weekly
Newsletter
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
America we're glad you're here open
phones at
88255 225 Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author and host of the Dr John deloney
show on the Ramsey networks is my
co-host today his new build new life
building a non New Life his new book
building a non-anxious life comes out in
under one week this coming Tuesday if
you want to get a great deal on it it's
only $20 right now and it includes on
pre-sale if you do it before Tuesday $75
worth of extra goodies so go check it
out the book will help you work through
and uh deal with properly the
preparation so when anxiety comes with
the six daily choices you've made not if
but when it comes you will know how to
deal with it uh so pick it up at ramsy
solutions.com get started Lynn is H
gonna start this hour off in
Philadelphia hi Lynn welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hey guys it's such an honor to
speak to you thanks for taking my call
sure what's up uh I actually have a
two-part question um not sure if I can
get to both of them but my first
question um is really starting to
something's really starting to get to me
it's affecting my family and my marriage
um my husband is taking
responsibility um for his parents my
in-laws
finances he's has created them a budget
he's paying their bills for them he's um
going as far as controlling their
expenses uh I'm not sure this is healthy
and it's causing friction is he using
their money or your money he's using
their money okay so it's not costing you
anything how old are they how old are
they um they are in their late 70s okay
and why is this not healthy do they need
help um let's just say that them doing
it on their own they haven't been doing
very well themselves MH um and I think
my husband is just afraid of you know
them overspending
and yeah but you you said you said this
is not healthy and it's driving you
crazy so why is it not healthy crazy why
is it not healthy and why is it driving
you crazy I don't think it's healthy
because he's taking over and doing it
himself um we don't agree with it so
he's causing friction with
us um and it's not that they're not able
to do it it's kind of like he wants to
do it for them because he thinks he'll
do it better could it be that he knows
for 79 years I've watched my parents
fail at this and they're getting really
close to falling off a financial cliff
that as my as their son I'm going to
feel some sort of obligation to help out
with and I can I can stop them from
driving off the edge is it that it is uh
100 100% that which I'm okay with but
he's kind of
gone a little too far not just giving
them advice but just basically there's
something else deeper why don't you do
you not like
them I love them they are my second
parents I lost my parents at a young age
when we just uh we've been married for
25 years so they've become my second
parents um so what's what's the thorn in
your side on
this you know I think it's
that I I think you know partly it's that
they can't do it themselves okay so are
you mad at them or him for
that I think I'm mad at them okay so
let's make sure the anger in the right
direction all right
and and
I probably part of me is just kind of
bombed that the time that we should be
spending together on our own finances is
kind of going toward them all right
that's a totally different
conversation one of those conversations
gets wrapped up and you're and you are
pressing your husband up against a wall
saying it's me or them and he's looking
and saying I love you both I dedicated
my life to you I said I do to you you're
my wife and I'm watching my parents
sliding off the
edge the real question you're asking is
I'm really frustrated that two grown
people who I love haven't and won't and
can't seem to figure out how to take
care of their money and my husband is
the kind of man who steps in that Gap
but I don't want that to come at the
expense of our marriage and our
relationship and our time together
planning for our future and so husband
can we spend time together focusing on
our finances that's separate then you
shouldn't be doing that with them you
see what I'm saying I do one of those
makes him have to wall up and pick and
the other says is makes calls is a
challenge are you going to be are you
going to be um my partner in this deal
and are you going to continue to dream
with me on what our house looks like so
you voiced to him that you're
frustrated I have he knows I'm he knows
I'm not a fan of the whole situation
okay so I let me tell you what I think I
heard you say and if I was wrong tell me
okay okay I think I heard you say I'm
frustrated because these two grown-ups
won't be grown-ups I love them but I
hate
irresponsibility and I hate the way that
they are just so lame when they don't
have to be and that aggravates me and
I'm also aggravated because you're
taking time away from us that I really
need to have some things done over here
on our finances before you go over
there uh you pretty much nailed it okay
why don't you say that back to him that
way I I think that's a really good idea
and can I throw one twist in there
that's going to be hard for you to say
sure
can you say I am proud that you're the
kind
of man that um sees his mom and dad in
need and however frustrating it is
you're willing to step in that
Gap yes that's super important I do
agree you are proud of his character you
just you you just hate it that they're
being so lame and I gotta tell you I
kind of agree with you yeah it's super
frustrating I'm aggravated at both of
them they're perfectly able-bodied and
able-minded to do this and they're just
too trifling to do it right you're yeah
yeah agates that aggravates people that
are
responsible right and you know that
that's I I agree with your aggravation
um I just don't think that uh your
aggravation is going to fix
it yeah because you're not you're being
aggravated is not going to make them
suddenly
responsible correct and so they're
either going to run in the ditch as John
said or over the edge as John said um or
your husband's probably going to do what
he's doing because you know they may
have seven years they might have 10 and
um you know and they're either going to
be a burden to you all financially cuz
they completely wreck the rest of their
lives here or your husband's going to do
this cuz they the chances of these
people changing their habits the old dog
new tricks at this stage probably pretty
low is that fair yes and can he go too
far can he say hey I'm going to help
y'all not fall off the edge and suddenly
become their mommy and daddy all in one
yes yeah and it's okay to call call that
out call them out on that yeah but yeah
sounds like you got a good man stuck in
a weird situation and it's frustrating
frustrating let's work towards the
solution you have a valid frustration
with their
irresponsibility but not a good
solution he's got a better solution this
is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
hey folks you know that sinking feeling
when you make an offer on a house you
love and then you hear there's another
offer you need the Churchill Mortgage
home buyer Edge super fast pre-approval
and a secured interest rate plus a
$5,000 seller guarantee gives your offer
the best chance of being accepted the
home buyer Edge from Churchill gives you
an advantage over those other guys go to
Churchill mortgage.com today to learn
[Music]
more
Dr John delone Ramsey personality my
co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 Lauren is in Chicago hey
Lauren welcome to the Ramsey
Show hi thank you for all the work you
guys do for um American people I um have
been listening for a couple months um to
a lot of the different shows
and my husband and I I'm learning a a
little and we are okay we've made um you
know some good decisions and some bad
decisions based on the ramcy way but
right now we're looking at wanting to
pay our house off we don't have any
other debt and how do people do that
like is it okay to just set aside the
money and then pay it off in one lump
sum or what is what's the ramsy weers or
recommendation or a book no it do take a
book it's just early and often every
month send as much towards the house
payment as you can
send okay and what happens is it lowers
your balance so the next month more of
your regular payment will go towards
principal than it than it would have if
you hadn't let's say you sent $110,000
okay well you no longer have to pay
interest on that $10,000 so the in the
monthly interest on that
$10,000 less will be low on the balance
will be lower than uh than it was by
$10,000 you follow
me I do I I understand that um I guess
like my husband and I and I agree with
it completely that's what I've learned
and understand however my husband's more
comfortable with having a um lump suum
available just in case um anything
happens with the house any emergency
yeah before you start paying your house
do you have an emergency fund of three
to six months of
expenses um we have an emergency we have
about
160,000 um saved and then we have in
okay your husband's theory is ludicrous
what do you what is he expecting kind
what kind of what do you think is GNA
happen
Armageddon your cash won't be good yes
there will not be ATMs during
Armageddon this is so funny thank you
for the laugh yeah that's no no no what
what do you owe on your
home uh we just I'm so grateful to God
we uh we we lived in like a thousand fo
how much you ow your home oh six uh 633
I'm sorry 633 we just what I would do if
I woke up in your shoes is I would take
three to six months of expenses given
that your husband likes to have a little
bit more let's say six months of what's
your household
income
250 okay all right so let's be super
generous okay set 100,000 aside
that's more than you need that's more
than 6 months okay and call that your
emergency fund it's a ridiculous
emergency fund it's set 100,000 side
everything above 100,000 is cray cray it
needs to be going on the
house it's just there you're not going
to have $100,000
emergencies can I ask another dumb
question no not dumb these AR dumb
questions these are great questions do
you ever recommend if like you have
Investments do you ever recommend taking
those out and putting it towards the
house always no always unless they're in
re unless they're in retirement
account okay you want to know why single
stock sell them you want to know
why why because when we studied the
largest study of millionaires ever done
in North America over 10,000 of them we
never found them saying we invested
instead of paying off our home and
that's how we became millionaires none
of them say that
okay almost all of them followed the
model of a steady reasonable amount of
investing like in their retirement
accounts then paid off the home and then
increased their investing when the home
was paid off and so the typical person
with say a million5 net worth their
first $1.5 million of net worth had A5
or $600,000 paid for home and about a
million dollar in their
401K but the number of them that said oh
we never pay off our house instead we
invested more and more and more and kept
the house debt was almost zero it was
less than
10% thank you that's helpful okay so the
data says that the best and the fastest
way to build wealth is get the house
paid off while steadily investing about
15% of your income above an emergency
fund of 3 to six months of expenses so
if you guys making 250 have squirel over
in an investment a half million dollars
I'm going to tell you get this house
paid off next 12 months and take that
money in there now not taking out 401K
money but I'm talking about you've just
got a you know you've got a brokerage
account of some kind over here with a
half million dollar sitting in it take
that and the 60 above the 100 and throw
it at the thing let's get this house
paid off CU I got to tell you if I ever
get your husband to pay off his house he
will think he's a genius and he'll never
ever ever go back back in dead on that
house well and I want to make sure we
point we we touch on this this he's
solving for safety and right now safety
for him is having a bunch of cash yep
and and non-retirement investment that's
right and he's hedging his safety
against all these other things and he's
got this big elephant sitting in his
living room and you We've joked about
this off air before no one has ever
called the show and said man I'm really
mad at y'all cuz I paid my house off 6
months later Dave Ramsey told me to pay
my house on I wish I had my mortgage
back I love my mortgage you could you
say it all time you could always go take
out a mortgage six months from now if
you don't like it right if you don't
like having a paid for house but you
think you're you think you're solving
for safety with all these
extracurricular activities try sleeping
in a house that you owe nobody anything
for that's a level of safety that you
didn't know your body could feel until
you go do it yeah I'm telling you when
when you have let's just talk about
safety okay when we have a fouchy
quarantine
and the whole freaking Place shuts down
and your house is paid for it feels a
whole lot different inside your physical
body than having the same amount of your
mortgage in a mutual fund because
there's a part of your brain that's been
there for eternity that says you're
going to lose your house your kids are
going to be on the street yeah 100% of
foreclosures happen on a house with a
mortgage that's right versus being real
frustrated right being annoyed and
frustrated that's different than I can't
breathe right yeah I mean I had uh we
had business stress we had relational
stress uh because of disagreements but
David Sharon Ro is going to be okay over
the covid you know we found out who our
friends were who who were all worried
about little CO's jumping on people and
all the stuff we de we dealt with all
that stuff uh but we didn't
deal during the fouchy quarantine with
the threat of foreclosure right not in
there and so when you're solving for
safety that was a good phrase I like
that phrase you know you you probably
need to really correctly Define safety
right and get the elephant out of your
dead gum living room right which is the
living room by the way yeah
ironically it it's and the way we said
it before we had John with two phds to
help us understand it was if your house
is paid for take your shoes off walk
through the backyard the grass feels
different you breathe different and um
you work you won't work at a toxic Place
anymore more because you have to you're
not stuck anymore folks and so the
solving for this is you know when I
first started teaching this stuff I
thought well if you got rid of a house
payment you invested a house payment you
can turn that money into a million
dollars pretty quick and that's the math
part the financial part but there's an
emotional part A Spiritual part A
relational part a medical health a
mental health part I you know someday it
it'll be done I I don't know that I'll
ever get around to doing it but a study
of the um medical condition and the life
quality of life and longevity of Life of
people who are debt free versus those
that aren't there're they're quietly
starting to to leak out into the world
where people are doing mental health and
emotional health and debt and starting
to use the coral of data it's it's it's
pretty frightening yeah and I've talked
to some doctoral students who interested
in doing their dissertations on student
loans and people with debt versus the
mental health of those who don't know
anybody anything yeah and if you think
about this think about think all of us
um um have had the moment in our career
when we think oh man I got to go have a
hard conversation with my boss I may not
survive this one imagine your wife or
your husband can put your face in their
hands and look at you and say hey we're
going to be okay we got plenty of money
go tell the truth we plent of money we
got no house payment go tell the truth
go be you and we don't have any house
payments man like that's a different
conversation here we go this is the
Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Spencer and Jordan are
with us in the Ramsey Solutions
headquarters Lobby on the debt free
stage hey guys how are you hey pretty
good welcome where do youall live terod
Indiana just I love it very good good to
have you all right how much debt have
you two paid we paid off
$150,000 we sold our house wow wow how
long did all this take uh well selling
the house took a couple months but uh we
lived in the house 3 and 1/2 years and
we downsized from 3,000 ft to about
1,200 with family of so
w but hey no mortgage payment so it's uh
worth it hardcore Wow way to sure you
all renting now no we bought it with
cash what we made from our other house
so yep oh so you bought a house so you
don't have a mortgage no morgage debt
free debt free you sold the house bought
another house with the equity no
mortgage of any kind how old are you to
I am 31 32 but in order to do this you
moved into a tiny little place yes sir
and I no regrets I it
okay but and you don't have to be there
forever it's a step yes it's a step and
and you're 32 years old and what's this
house worth that you're living in uh 130
135 range I'd say we we actually just
cash flow to remodel on it too so um
okay so so it's it's pretty nice okay
and we can live there for a few years
and then move up easy easy easy and uh
so okay again so this whole experien has
really did gone down pretty quick right
yes sir but uh we actually uh grew up in
and and you know Ramsay um uh
foundations right we we have family
members who have followed the um bab
steps and passed that on to us um Jordan
actually has a great story with the ttal
Money Makeover yeah when I was a junior
in high school my parents saw that I was
not great with money and they were like
we'll pay you $20 to read The Total
Money Makeover so great
$20 um it did not stick until I got
married so not a great
but no no it was spent probably the next
day but I inherited $13 when we got
married yep pardon that $20 and then uh
yeah big shout out to my mom who's uh
followed Dave Ramsey for a long time in
those steps and uh all the way through
college um we were able to to kind of
cash flow so this this all this stuff
was around in your childhood you're kind
of financial peace babies in a sense yes
sir okay all right now but once you
decided okay we got this big house we
could sell it we could buy another house
you did all that within a matter of
months yep so really like four months or
something to be de free once you make
the call right yep yes sir you have
other debt to pay off too no we paid off
my student loans um when was it a few
years ago M and uh we had a two and a
half threee gap of no loans no no being
debt free and then we bought the house
29 sold it um earlier this spring so so
what lit y'all up what what said like
hey let's leave this big nice house
where everyone's got their own bathroom
and room and let's get out of this mess
yeah you know we just it was a it was it
was a great it was a big beautiful house
and we just were like you know what we
want to change and we knew that that
wasn't our forever home um so we were
like why are we paying this big mortgage
when we could downsize be completely
debt free and then save for what will be
our forever home mhm way to go you guys
very cool what's your household income
right now it's around 110 what do you
you all do for a living I stay home and
homeschool our three kids M and I'm
currently in the International Guard
working in it and then my civilian jobs
in it as well so wow good for you good
career y are both awesome yeah yeah way
to go guys you're Heroes okay
congratulations um to all of the young
parents out there who say there's no
possible way you could have three
beautiful
rambunctious little ones uh what is the
oldest one what six seven he's nine nine
okay so you got nine and seven and five
y yes sir you can't possibly have a
family of five in a 12200 foot house
it's awesome how do you make it work
bonding no it's a it's a lot of bonding
yeah the boys share bedroom and Remy our
daughter she has her own room and
honestly it's probably been a lot harder
for them than it has for us it's a lot
less cleaning a lot less maintaining for
us and I think they're getting used to
it a lot of times Outdoors but we
haven't uh gone through winter yet so
we'll see how cut it is January February
range I had one sibling I grew up in a
1,000 ft home yep so um and um yeah wow
yeah it's amazing when you look I went
over there and visited it not long ago
it kind of shrunk yeah that's so it's
like going back to your Elementary
School at shrunk you know yes yes but I
I think you guys are going to be great
I'm so proud of y'all yeah it's not a
longterm play really it's a short-term
play it's a it's a sacrifice and we knew
it when we when we bought the house and
we actually
um you you think about 1,000 bucks a
month going to the bank and it's like
you what could we be doing with this and
knowing that we were going to um buy a a
forever home from a family member um in
the future um we can be saving that and
you know treat this house as a rental
for the kids as they go through school
yeah that' be great but no it's a and
with the homeschool stuff so in your
all's case you made this with one Fell
Swoop you grew up with some of these
things around you what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
cuz your story is different um for me it
would just be the budgeting was the
hardest part for us I think was just
sitting down and making a budget and I
feel like it's gotten even harder now
that we are debt free is sitting down
and still maintaining that budget but I
think that that's what I tell people is
get on the same page sit down write a
budget do what's best for your family
yeah the discipline and the um the
reminder that it's God's money right be
a good Steward of it and the lesson for
the kids and all the way going through
the house selling and the house buying
process with them by our sides um a lot
of um OPP well you took a step back so I
I think looking at you from the outside
looking in I think your secret was
contentment yeah you're willing to be
content with that as a step uh I'm going
to live like no one else so later I can
live and give like no one else being
counter cultural and knowing that it's
um just it's God's will doing it so we
often tell people don't sell your house
to get out of debt cuz you don't you
don't go through you don't learn the
lessons y'all y'all were debt free for 3
years before you sat down and said let's
go do something radical yep yeah very
well done good job you guys very cool
all right bring the kiddos up let's hear
their names and ages have they been
practicing any debt-free screams little
bit just since we've been here this is
Grayson he is nine milin who's seven and
Remington who is five go Remington all
right I think Remington's in charge John
anytime ofan family has their kids come
up and they all just stand in a straight
line and they're respectful and kind
that's great it's very cool makes me
want to be better at being a
parent I love it very good you guys hey
we've got The Total Money Makeover book
for you the baby steps millionaires book
that's the next chapter in your story
for you and the Financial Peace
University membership you can live some
of that you can give some of that thanks
for coming down here from terot and
sharing your inspiring story and your
beautiful family you guys are amazing
way to go Heroes you're Heroes you took
control those little babies right there
their whole lives are changed cuz their
mom and dad are grown-ups very well done
Spencer Jordan Grayson milin and Remy I
got to love it from terao 150,000 paid
off in about four months sold their home
moved into a smaller one so they added
all paid off making 110 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
1 we de
free
[Applause]
yeah wow
wow
fabulous
fabulous in 1963 the average family in
America had a 1,000 square ft one level
home one
car that was the average family in
America today the average family in
America has 2.5 cars and 2900 Square ft
you me tell you something wild about
that besides just the cost um one of my
PL plans to go down a nerd rabbit hole
is there's some quiet conversations
about families over the last you know
centuries and thousands of years have
grown up together you could hear each
other breathe you could see each other
and that one of the causes of anxiety
may be that everybody from you get into
the bassinet you get your own room and
you're on the other side of the house
you're upstairs someone's downstairs and
you're all on screens everybody's alone
and everybody's on screens and there's
something about bringing the family back
together that's that's kind sounds kind
of neat I don't know the data on it kind
of regulates everything but it's
interesting it's interesting thought
regulates their bodies overnight we
stuck everybody in their own room on the
other side of the house and I don't know
that we're designed for that interesting
thing to think about this is the ramsy
[Laughter]
show
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality open
phones a triple
88255 225 you jump in we'll talk about
your life and your money Joe Is With Us
in Springfield Hey Joe welcome to the
Ramsey
Show Dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up I've been listen to you
often on last couple years it hasn't a
lot of things haven't soaked in but the
other day you said that nobody should
own a new truck truck unless they have a
net worth of a million and they're debt
free well I bought a new one earlier
this year and so my question number one
is should I sell that truck and
downgrade get something a little bit
more economical so that I can pay it
off how much do you
ow uh
43 no 42 and some change so 43 what's
your household
income 220 210 and you don't have any
money no I have uh I have about 40 in
the bank right
now how long you been making that kind
of
money years you're making good money why
do you not have
any
well my wife kind of lives YOLO I kind
of live like hey we might live to be 500
and it's just it's been 15 years of just
kind of we've sat down and we' put
budgets together and it just it uh it
doesn't stick on one end and it does on
one and I've just kind of learned to
compromise to keep the marriage happy
and uh but the marriage isn't happy man
I can hear it on
you it's frustrating I mean I love her
to death wouldn't trade her for nothing
but it's frustrating you know when you
have a divided house um you know like I
hate Christmas I hate
it um you know we spend $44,000 every
year in Christmas and it's to people and
friends and and every year we are about
it and it just gets me where I just hate
Christmas you know because I know we're
just going to blow a bunch of money and
we shouldn't and we don't have to you
know you you move on you know you can
either dwell on it or you can just move
on and and then and then you borrowed
40,000 on a truck
yeah yes well I I'm a sales guy so I
have to have a truck that's less than
three years old and so many miles I get
paid 850 a month for my truck allowance
and whether you have a car payment or
not that's right and that's where I
would rather tuck to 850 and throw it on
the house we're in a great situation on
the house house is worth about six six
and a quarter we're down to about 270 on
it okay um Joe Joe the the truck the
truck needs to be paid off or it needs
to be sold but it's 10% of your
problem okay the problem that's
screaming at me in this conversation is
you make way too much money to be this
broke I agree and you guys have really
got to sit down and address that you're
just you're you're just a quarter no you
haven't you because it's not fixed what
do you but what do you do well I think
you need if you can't if you and your
wife can't sit down and dream about a
future that you're willing to control
yourselves for CU you're not controlling
yourselves you're you have no
self-control in your household and if
you the two of you can't find a house a
dream in in high definition that the two
of you can agree to that is worth
working towards together and worth not
spending everything we make to cause it
to happen then you do need to sit down
with a marriage counselor if that's the
case
often High performing High earning folks
sit down and have this conversation as a
math problem honey we make this much
money we got to make a
budget no I have one I have an Excel
sheet I can show you I know you
do here's what I'm telling you there's a
different conversation when you sit down
with your wife and you hold her hands
and you say
honey I can't breathe
I'm so scared we make way too much money
I'm working so
hard and I feel like you and I are
fulling pulling further and further and
further apart and I love you too much to
be frustrated at you all the time
because I know that's hard to live with
and I love you too much for us to
pretend that we're all joyful and happy
once a year at Christmas and we try to
throw money at our friends and family
instead of being a warm safe place for
them to come
land would you build something different
with me that's a different conversation
then honey look at my spreadsheet look
at this if you just would do this then
we could get out of this crap one of
those she's going to go to her defense
and that defense is probably way older
than you and that's probably been there
since she was a little kid and then you
go to your defense because she starts
bombing you back and it's different when
you take ownership and say I want my
wife and I want a family that um I want
to unific a unified front here I want a
unified vision of what we're going to do
and I'm scared to death I'm going to
lose you the iron is is that you think
by acquiescing you're creating peace and
you're not that's the irony the fire is
burning in the basement and it is hot
it's coals yeah and because this it's
eating you up and she can feel that on
you and then she goes about solving that
feeling with the way that her body's
been solving those feelings for her
whole life spending spending and trying
to make people feel good about
themselves and showing people how great
she's
doing and that's different than y'all
two building a life together yeah yeah
and if you guys can't sit down work that
through and start to say we need to
develop a new vision for our future a
different plan other than just spinning
our Wheels feeling like a rat in a wheel
I'm scared I can't do this this is
killing me I cannot live in a situation
where I make a quar million dollars a
year and we have nothing that is just
absurd to me my brain can't do it
anymore my mind can't do it my psyche my
spirit can't do it anymore so we've got
to develop a plan for the future that
we're both willing to work towards and I
want to do that with you let's start
fresh fresh a reset not we've got to get
on a budget some but that will lead you
by the way to a budget and it's not a
spreadsheet budget it's an every dollar
budget but it'll lead you to the two of
you working together to implement the
plan that you have agreed to together
that both of you had a vote in I love
starting those conversations with I'm
sorry I'm sorry I've tried to control
you the way I know to control a problem
I've tried to solve you I've tried to
fix you I'm sorry let me tell you the
truth I'm scared to death and there's a
different there's a different approach
there someone can enter into your space
that way instead of uh having to swing
back at you it's tough hope that works
for you brother and then pay that truck
off in the next 20 minutes um or couple
months and or sell it one of the two
that's um because it's you know you went
and bought a truck while she went and
bought Christmas I think you yeah you
showed her I think you spent more so um
there you go and the 850 is coming in
whether you have a truck payment or not
so that doesn't justify it our question
of the day is sponsored by neighborly
your hub for Home Services most American
homes have dozens of appliances and
chances are at any given time something
wrong with at least one of the Mr
Appliance a neighborly brand offers
expert appliance service on your
schedule visit neighborly decom today to
find Home Service Experts including Mr
Appliance in your area today's question
comes from Jane in Florida I pay the
bills for my elderly father he has a bad
habit of going to the ATM to withdraw
money several times a week A lot of
times it leaves me with a balance too
low to pay his bills I've had numerous
talks threatened to stop helping etc etc
he apolog apologizes and Promises to do
better then in a few weeks he's right
back to the same situation I don't want
to be disrespectful to him but is it
really it's really stressing me out what
do you recommend I do I'm not going to
help you with your bills anymore unless
you give me your ATM card yeah I'm
unable to help anymore unless you give
me your ATM card I can't I can't
participate yeah you you you're you're
making this too hard you're sabotaging
everything I'm trying to do to help you
I'm trying to love you and you're
clearly you're telling me very clearly
you don't want my love and support and
help yeah so if you want to give me the
ATM card I'll keep doing it if you don't
then I won't yeah it's fine I still love
you but I'm not going to I'm not going
to spend all of my time resenting how
you're living your life and then you
come to me asking for help I don't want
to resent you you're my dad I want to
love you so I'm either going to turn
this over to you or you're going to hand
me your ATM card yeah that's easy yeah I
can fix that and it's not a flex and
it's not it's not showing your muscles
it's just saying hey I'm choosing to not
do this anymore I can't yeah this is
this is an absurd dog chasing its tail
keep pulling you out of the pool and you
just keep jumping in if you want to stay
in there man it's tough I keep getting
you out of the road and you keep running
back out there yeah it's tough yeah it's
um it's well it's um it's frustrating
because a it's someone you love and B
they're hurting the themselves eles and
um and see it's so cyclical yeah it's
it's it's circular here it's a dance the
whole thing is circular it's ridiculous
yeah Stop Dancing bad Florida twostep
there you go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsey Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsey Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Dr John deloney Ramsey
personality number one bestselling
author host of the Dr John deloney show
is my co-host today this hour we're
going to be talking about one of my
favorite subjects baby steps
millionaires people have become
millionaires we want to talk to real
millionaires you see when I started
doing this Radio Show in
1992 over 30 years ago I had this idea
and I still do that if we taught gods
and M's ways of handling money live on
less than you
make have a written
plan get out of debt and stay out of
debt steadily invest and
save and be outrageously generous if you
do those five things consistently in
your life that over a period of time you
would become
wealthy it's a mathematical fact number
one but number two it's just the fastest
right way to become wealthy and now here
I said 30 plus years later and there's
lots of you have become millionaires
doing this stuff lots of you and if you
did it following the baby steps we call
you a baby steps millionaire you do not
have to be a baby steps millionaire to
be on this show today but you do need to
be a millionaire and for some of you
that are new to this let me help you
with this a millionaire is an accounting
term it's not a feeling I don't feel
like I have much it doesn't matter what
you feel couldn't care less about your
feelings this is not a feelings show
that's John's
show H it is uh no one should have that
much money well this is not a moral
construct it's not a discussion of
wealth inequality although I can go
there if you want me to um it it's not
any of that a millionaire is simply an
accounting term it's your net worth well
he's a net worth millionaire that's the
only kind of millionaire there is it's a
redundant statement okay your network
worth is your what you own minus what
you owe assets minus liabilities when
that equals a million dollar regardless
of what the assets
are regardless of what the liabilities
are when assets minus liabilities own
versus o equals a million dollars you're
a
millionaire and it's not as much money
as it used to be it might not be enough
to do some of the things you want to do
but it's more than most people have
there's about 17 millionaire 17 million
millionaires in North America
so they're out there they're all around
us I meet them every day when I'm doing
the show every single day when I take a
break during this show at a commercial
break I walk outside and someone comes
up to get their picture taken with me I
sign a book or two and I always meet at
least one millionaire every day and they
came by to say hey this is the place
this is where I learned all this stuff
this is how it's almost like a a visit
to uh a shrine uh that caused them to be
able to do it and obviously we didn't do
it we didn't give them any money we just
said you could do it we made you believe
you could do it and we showed you how
and what the steps are in the Tactical
moves with money but there's no magic
pill
here and here's the truth it can be done
and we're going to prove it by talking
to real millionaires today Blake is with
us in Nashville Blake what's your net
worth my net worth is like5 to $6
million good for you okay give me a
little breakdown by category on that
yeah so um I've got a couple million
dollars in stocks mutual funds um couple
million dollars in uh some a real estate
property uh and then the valuation of uh
the couple businesses is between you
know1 to3 million okay all right in a
business I got about a 100,000 cash hand
so how old are you I am 32 actually be
33 tomorrow wow happy birthday and how
much of this 5 million did you inherit
it uh zero the only thing I inherited is
a common sense and financial sense so
that's a that's one thing I've inherited
but no dude 5 million at 33 is Pretty
stinking impressive from zero yes sir
thank you so what has been your best
year income and your worst year income
since you've been working the last 13
years or so well I own my own business
um and of course starting off it that
took you know no income 13 years ago um
but my highest year would probably be
last year and did right at seven figures
right at a million and then this year
we're looking at um doing about 60 to
70k a month okay and we're talking about
profit here taxable income yes sir way
to go man what kind of a business have
you
got uh actually it's a a martial arts
school I I do own some properties too
but um I grew up doing martial arts and
when I was 19 I opened a opened a school
and uh that's been the the rest is
history so it's it's been very fortunate
to be able to take a passion and make a
career you know not only changed my life
but those around me as well very cool
you have a four-year
degree yes I I have a uh degree in
business finance what was your G GR in
2012 um gosh probably
3.6 3.7 something like that okay so you
would say I think if I'm listening to
your story correctly that the way you
became a millionaire was were very
successful in
business correct yeah I've I've uh
always tried to learn from other
people's experience and wisdom and try
not to duplicate some of their mistakes
and and uh uh yeah just a lot of good
decisions and planning things out and uh
I lived with my parents till I was about
26 so you have to pay everything off and
make sure that uh you know I was
financially set I spent some time doing
martial arts myself not nearly with the
lifelong commitment you've made how much
of that slow and steady and just
discipline and doing the same things
over and over again how much of that
have have you used in the business world
because it sounds like you've like if I
look back you've moved really quickly to
gain this much net worth but at the same
time it sounds like you've just been
pretty methodical and pretty wise about
your next
steps yeah I think that uh you know
martial arts the self discipline that
comes with martial arts you know I
started when I was eight years old U and
I think that the discipline that learned
from that uh it kind of bled over into
uh my being able to make good financial
decisions and you know I tell my
students before you can learn to do
something have to learn to do nothing
and uh you just take your time and think
and plan things out instead of making
you know irrational decisions based on
emotion wow okay there's a 19-year-old
version of you out there what do you
tell them the secret
is um I think it's a kind of a two-part
uh two-part uh secret uh or answer I
guess but um I think the the first thing
is being able to find a mentor uh
someone that you that you look up to
whether it's you know your based on your
financial uh you know goals financially
or whether it's a relationship or faith
um and then follow them listen to them
and then part two like I we just touched
on is being able to have the self-d
discipline to follow through with it and
do it you know
consistently dude you're a stud man
you're a hero well done that's
absolutely amazing starting from nothing
and uh $5 million at 33 years old happy
birthday wow leave your contact
information with Christian on the phone
there cuz I've been looking for a school
for my two kids and you're exactly the
kind of man that I want my kids learning
from so leave your leave your school
info I'm you're you're you just knocked
my socks off my man very cool good stuff
man good stuff this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour on the ramsy
[Music]
show
on
[Music]
[Applause]
it's a baby steps millionaires theme
hour Dr John deloney Ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones atle
88255 225 is we take questions from only
millionaires actually we don't want to
take questions we're actually going to
give you the questions we're going to
interview you and find out how you got
here the misnomer is that millionaires
can't happen in America today unless
you're a movie star or a sports figure
or a music icon of some kind and the
truth is among people that have a
million dollar net worth or greater
those three categories put together
account to less than 1% of the
millionaires hey you you wrote about a
thing in baby steps millionaires that it
was a light bulb moment for me I would
love for you to talk about a little bit
you have a section called millionaires
are not billionaires and I thought that
was an instructive conversation to have
well yeah it's it's um I think sometimes
when because the the whole thing on
millionaire became a thing in the
20s because a millionaire then was a lot
lot of money billionaire in the 1920s
probably a billionaire yeah and and so
it was like the game Monopoly was
developed about that time right and so
everything is around this idea of
acquiring and building a net worth of a
million dollars because that was rich
that became the definition of rich and
Easy Street you're going to be on Easy
Street and so then but what is happened
is over the years then the people think
it's not attainable to become a
millionaire which is a really good place
to be as a minimum starting point going
into your retirement it's not necessary
that you're there to live but you you
know that that sets you up for a pretty
strong golden years it does not set you
up for opulence okay and so like for
instance no millionaires almost no
millionaires own a
jet almost no millionaires own a
$400,000 Lamborghini or seven cars okay
almost no millionaires have uh a house
uh at the beach a house in the mountains
and a house that is a house most of them
have one house that's it so it's a it's
a that's instructive for me because when
I think I could never have that no
because that's not the goal well it's
not the first goal you could get there
but a b see a billion is a thousand
million when you think about that it's a
thousand times more than a millionaire
well yeah they've got a jat yeah they've
got seven cars and yeah they got four
houses but they got a thousand times
more money that's it's still a uh it's
still 5% of their net worth right
exactly exactly but I mean it's a it's
so but what what I the reason I wanted
to point that out is in the book and
when we're talking about it is not that
a billion is bad and a million is good
that's not the point or or that you but
but if you think of I'll never have
enough money to have a jet a house three
houses and seven cars then you're not
thinking about a million dollars you're
thinking about a billion dollars and so
yeah that is there are a lot fewer of
those right you know when I started this
show only 300 of the 400 Forbes 400
wealthiest people were billionaires even
now 100% of them are billionaires and it
requires Pro you know quite a several
billion to even be on that list you know
and so but that's you know the the
number of billionaires there are in
America whoo way less than millionaires
so it's it's okay to be a billionaire if
you want to call me and tell me how you
got to be a billionaire oh by the way
you're not going to become a billionaire
mathematically with your 401k right and
you're paid for a house but you will
become a millionaire with those two
things uh which is the first step you
know the first 1 to five million to hit
there so uh you know but but you don't
talk the uh of the people on the fors
400 the billionaires um 67% of them are
first generation they did not inherit
their money two out of three that's
that's a bunch I mean so that says it
can still be done but uh like 90 uh not
I think all of them I'll have to go back
and look I looked at it one time it may
be one or two that inherited money of
the ones that made it the started from
nothing all of them owned and ran big
businesses his business yeah lightning
struck yeah they they you know Michael
Dell Dell computers right Bill Gates
Microsoft right Apple uh you know you go
through and you look at the tech world
you go through and look at um uh uh uh
you know uh Elon Kathy family Tri
Chick-fil-A okay Elon Musk um you know
those Elon and uh uh Buffett are the two
number number one number two and Bezos
you know but Bezos started his Elon
started his from nothing yeah they both
came from nothing and so but that's but
but don't confuse those two if uh it
because it can lead you to losing hope
that it can be done cuz the millionaire
is very attainable billionaire you got
to you got to run a business you got to
run a big business it can be done but
you're not going to do that with your
401k not mathematically not you can't
put enough in there to get there it's
that simple Margaret is with us in
Washington DC Margaret you're net worth
uh 5.6 million and I feel like I'm slow
to I feel like I'm slow to the dance
based on that last caller because he's
32 and I'm 57 we're all slow to the
dance after that last caller I'll just
tell you so you're 57 all right give me
a little breakdown on that uh 5.6
million sure it uh our home
um we beach home a commercial office
space small commercial office space is
worth what about 3 point uh 3.1 3.2 okay
and the remaining amount are 401ks IRAs
annuity um liquid assets um just a whole
so another 2.5 of that correct okay all
right very Co you'd be proud of me I
spoke to you last December and you told
me here I was crazy that I kept a
balance on my beach house mortgage AG
because I had so much in cash and today
after talking to Dawn I went to the bank
and I paid off the remaining beach beach
house balance all right you can't come
on the air again without that thing paid
off that's what John told me and you
know John you made me go back in deck
because I bought your book
today well if you're going to go back in
debt buy a hundred of them then yeah go
all right how much of this 5.6 did you
inherit zero all right and your best
year working income your worst year
working income combined um about 450
between myself and my husband um worst
case probably when I got out of college
maybe making about 36 okay and what's
your
careers um I'm in sales I work for
myself um my husband's an attorney and
um yeah so I've always been in business
for myself and I always say I have a
great boss okay cool well obviously he
has a law degree what's your degree um
my undergrad was education in Spanish I
was going to be a Spanish teacher and
then I got into the computer field and
then at age 50 I got my Master's in in
business NBA no actually I I have a love
for nutrition and food studies and
wanted to become a nutritionist but then
I found out there's no money in it so I
stuck with my business all right but I
still do nutrition on the side love it
okay and what was your
GPA um as a master's it was 4.0 um
undergrad I didn't really that was
terrible like 3.3 I should have was
awful I can't believe you did
that okay oh man I've got I've got two
questions for you um the first one is
how much of that did you
steal U zero all right all right I
thought y'all were all crook yeah no no
none at all all right the second one is
how many books do you read a month you
know I'm ashamed because I I don't I I
read probably two a year because by the
time my kids I mean my my son just
graduated from college my daughter's in
college and I'm exhausted I still open
the books and I fall asleep fall asleep
that's I've been I've been there the
last few months hey so that makes that
makes me even more grateful that you
read one to two books a year and you
bought his book you bought mine that
makes my heart full thank you and I have
your other book as well and I do I do I
am reading intentional living by John
Maxwell um and uh
so I just don't read enough I'm
embarrassed to tell you don't be
embarrassed or ashamed you should read
anything John Maxwell writes he's
awesome we love we love John you're
doing great yeah yeah I'm really
enjoying it my book will for sure put
you to sleep so Dave I have to tell you
really really can I tell you something
really quick that I had told Don and she
said you got to tell Dave this sure I
made a stupid mistake when I got out of
college I had a Mazda Arc 7 beautiful
California ocean blue me and my husband
at the time my ex-husband and we
couldn't afford the tires and they were
going to be over $1,000 dollar to put
new tires on so I thought I was a really
Savvy business business person and I
said let's go to the Honda dealership
and let's lease a car for $200 a month
and uh we'll save ourselves
$800
stupid I mean that was probably the
dumbest thing I've ever done and then
you still ended up with 5.6 million by
57 you overcome the Thousand Tire deal
well done awesome way to go Margaret
good talking to you this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour on the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today it's a baby steps
millionaires theme hour anybody that has
a net worth of a million dollars you're
welcome to call in we want to know how
much you got how you did it so that
other people can learn from you learn
what we call in business best
practices how'd you do it so we can do
it Zach is with us in Salt Lake City
Zach what's your net
worth hi Dave and John it's uh 1.8
million somewhere around there excellent
and give me a little breakdown by
category
so a paid off house it's around a
million dollars um Ira SEP IRA and and a
brokerage account invested in mutual
funds around
450,000 I've got a CD with $200,000 in
it and then our you know high yield
savings with 150,000 that way to go how
old are you 37 all right very good and
how much of this did you
inherit
zero zero all right I love love it very
good cool cool and your income your best
year and your worst
year best year was around 650,000 whoa
and uh worst year was around 50,000 okay
cool what do you do for a living yeah I
uh I run a sales team for a Solar
Company wow okay cool you four-year
degree no degree I went for three years
and and uh found out sales as my and and
so I I never finished but but $650,000
later you figured it out huh I guess so
yeah way to go man very very cool all
right what do you tell the uh younger
version of you is it still possible
today to become a millionaire starting
from nothing like you
did absolutely in fact I think it's it's
probably easier today than ever to
become there's a lot of good lot of good
opportunities out there and uh you know
I think I wish I'd have known years ago
I called in to the show last year and um
I was actually a a net worth millionaire
last year before I started following
your plan and I called in and you you
gave me some encouragement to go ahead
and pay off my house and and everything
so I wish that I'd have started younger
um I always lived under my means but I I
wish that I started following you know
avoiding debt and and investing younger
and one one thing that I do want to say
is is uh you know there's a lot of
people that you know disagree I guess
with paying off a mortgage early they
say hey you should keep that money you
know keep the mortgage and invest the
money or whatever and I I get their
argument but the thing that I really
like about what you teach is once you
have that mortgage paid off um it's a
lot easier to invest into retirement and
and other things I'm investing a lot of
money right now every month on on
autopilot and I if I would have had a
mortgage or car payments I wouldn't be
doing those Investments and that's
probably the best argu I've heard from
from Ramsey on on that yeah you know my
contention also is and I ask you about
this because it's interesting to me um
is that when you're running a business a
small business like you are um uh that
you make different decisions when you
have zero debt at
home absolutely I'm more confident in
the decisions I make here at Ramsey
because I don't have to worry about the
home
front I agree yep and therefore I think
I think I end up making more money here
because of that I think I agree I think
I there's no desperation
decisions it's a lot easier to make a
sale when you don't have to make the
sell I agree yeah because uh broke
salespeople smell bad they do and you
can also break up with those customers
that are just driving you mad um you
could say you know I'm GNA move on
because I don't I don't I don't need
this I don't have to have this so that
my family can eat and hey so while we
got you you got a lot of money in CDs
and a savings account are you saving for
something big Yeah Yeah we actually have
a a family friend that's uh he's
developing some land up here um about a
mile or two from my house it should be
ready in the next year so that's why
I've been piling money up there so that
when it comes available I want to I want
to buy a lot with cash good knows
deloney fantastic hey and one more thing
so um you're a good case study for me
I'm always telling folks listen I get
the if you're one of those folks who
bought a house at 2.9% I get the math
problem there it's an excellent math
problem in your favor especially when
you look
historically you had that you had a
house on the front end of this and then
you're a millionaire and then you
thought I'm just going to pay this thing
off what kind of piece do you have in
your house do you feel different tell me
if I'm crazy because I don't mind being
wrong in fact I'm wrong a lot but is it
does it feel different it's my it's
yours
it feels a lot different what what Dave
always says about you know walking
barefoot in the grass it just feels
different it you don't really know that
feeling until you go ahead and and pay
off the house and so I I'll never go
into debt again and and a lot of my
friends kind of laugh at that and they
think oh you you know when you build a
house you will and I said no I'll uh I'm
gonna save up and and and maybe go a
little bit slower but it it's silly to
me to think that I had a mortgage and
and and car payments before now that
you're out of it I don't want ever want
to go back
and the feeling is really really good
yeah way to go I'm proud of you man yeah
you're a stud man you're a hero way to
go very proud of you good work Ann is
with us in Columbus Ohio and your net
worth just at 2.5 million love it okay
and uh how old are
you I'm 46 my husband is 52 all right
very cool give me a little breakdown by
category on the two and a half
million it's 1 7 in retirement 600 in
our paid off home $100,000 in cash and
another 100 in other miscellaneous
Investments very good 29 and perfect mix
well done how much of this did you
inherit well a few years ago many years
ago I got $4,000 when my grandmother
passed away okay so it's safe to say you
are not a millionaire because of an
inheritance
no but I do have good parents yeah I
didn't say that hey I just I want you to
know if you watch this on YouTube live I
just laughed but not at your
Grandmother's passing you set this up
and I thought you were GNA say I got a
million dollars but you said I got 4,000
bucks yeah so what's your best year
working income since you've been working
and your worst
year well our worst year was back during
the beginning of the stay-at-home mom
years and it was about 70,000 and our
best year will probably be this year
where it should be around 440,000 wow
but um it's only been like that the last
so many years since we're empty nesters
so most of those years were you know
under 100,000 100 to 150 we went back
and looked and um where we are today
especially from the retirement front is
based on what we did during the years
where we didn't make a lot of money it's
much less based on what we do
today what we're doing today I hear you
yeah so what what do you what do you do
for a living and what's your husband do
what's your
careers um we're both mechanical
engineers by degree I work in marketing
and he works in project
management okay and I assume you have
engineering degrees both of
you yes okay and your um GPS
uh well so remember the engineer it was
a threep point for me because that's
what I needed to keep my scholarship or
my parents were making me pay for school
and it was 2.7 for my husband's
undergrad and he actually got accepted
into a master's program conditionally
because they were concerned about his um
2.7 GPA but he worked fulltime all the
way through college yeah wow you guys
are incredible what's your advice to the
younger version of you
listening uh one really important thing
is be very intentional about who you
marry somebody with shared values shared
goals somebody who's
hardworking take FPU early um taking
Financial Peace University we didn't
take it till 2013 and it was rocket fuel
we had a lot of the the basics in place
but that's really really what brought
everything together wow thanks for the
ad that was
awesome just amazing very well done
thank you an we appreciate you you're
amazing I'm so proud of you guys way to
go hero this is a baby steps
millionaires theme hour on the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
our scripture of the day Philippians
4:12 I know what it is to be in need and
I know what it is to have plenty I have
learned the secret of being content in
any and every situation whether wellfed
or hungry whether living in plenty or in
want David Lee Roth said money can't buy
you happiness but it can buy you a big
yacht a yacht big enough to pull up
alongside
it oh my goodness well done uh Wayne is
in Chattanooga Wayne you're net
worth hey uh Dave thanks for taking my
call um 3.4 million good for you all
right how old are you give give or take
give or take a month you know how okay
how old are you I'm 62 62 all right and
give me a little break give me a little
breakdown on the 3.4 million all right
so I will say let's say nine years ago I
had about a million dollars Dave um and
since that time uh in that million
dollar was in a TR mostly in a
traditional
401K uh so you know taxable um and since
that time I've made a few uh real estate
Investments um and have basically in
that nine years changed that million to
over $3 million good for you through
multiple some of it being um residential
and then uh you know um one of those
Investments was uh a commercial
investment so um yeah that's kind of
where it's ended up um I I'm I'm debt
free uh my home's worth approximately
425,000
um and that's kind of where I'm at good
for you well done okay yeah all right
and what was your how much of this did
you
inherit well that's a funny story uh my
father passed away when I was very young
um I inherited U
$7,000 um and as a and I was a teenager
uh at that point I I bought a car or a
truck for 3500 bucks so left me with
$3,500
and so I decided my grandfather was a uh
he invested and I didn't know anything
about it but what I did know is I knew
that it it it really my grandfather was
he ended up very wealthy so um I wanted
to kind of Follow that path so I went to
the bank and the banker said to me he
says uh yeah you know I had $3,500 said
just put it in your savings account I
saidwell I'm not really I don't really
want to do that and uh so ultimately I
put in 30 I put in $500 into a savings
account and then I had $3,000 left and
and through the help of my grandfather
and I was 17 years old at the time uh
helped me invest that into a mutual
fund um which was a Fidelity mellin Fund
I'm sure you're familiar that yeah
what's it worth
today uh hundreds of thousands
I never I never touched it that's
incredible and it um and I think for the
younger the younger generation to
understand what investing is about I had
to go to a
facility we had to go somewhere make an
appointment in order for me to invest
that 300
$3,000 uh and it there was a fee
attached to it it was it was a process I
mean today I could do that in 60 seconds
you know uh and I and I believe today
Building Wealth is so much easier than
it was when you and I were growing up
you're right you're right and and so is
destroying it both are easier is it's so
is destroying it it it absolutely is um
but I think I I think it's it's it's so
much easier today if I if I were myself
back then uh planed today it'd be so
much easier I'd be worth tens of
millions of dollars more I mean there's
no question there's no question about it
if I knew then what I know now wow
absolutely way to go Wayne proud of you
man excellent job Dave I I I'm I'm just
struck now this is a small sample size
but everyone we've talked to today has
been generating wealth significantly
several of our callers said they've had
their best years this year or last year
recently mhm and every shred of news I
get from every angle of my life is how
the economy's falling apart there's no
way to get ahead everybody everything's
awful it's all coming down and all the
calls we took today people are saying
well it's it's the time and apparently
someone uh decided not to participate in
the recession High interest rates and
high we can't do it with they're just
they just are one guy's a Salesman
somebody else is a Salesman somebody
else is
a two salespeople an attorney a martial
arts uh owner two mechanical engineers
um best year ever best year ever best
year ever yeah yeah this year this year
this year despite the inflation despite
nobody spending money 5.5 million 5.6
million 1.8 million 2.5 million 3.4
million no one inherited anything
appreciably I mean that was subst
nothing substantial that made them a
millionaire and so the idea that all
millionaires are inherited money 79% of
millionaires are study inherited zero
another 5% inherited a small amount like
these 4,000 $4,000 $7,000 but not enough
to make you a millionaire and another 5%
inherited substantial money after they
were already millionaires so 5 and five
and 79 is 89 so that will help tell you
that nine out of 10 of America's
millionaires are first generation Rich
did it without an inheritance so when
these left-wing nut jobs tell you that
it's all over and the only thing that's
going to work for you is Carl Marx
because they're college professor who's
a communist told them that uh and then
they tell you that it's impossible to
get ahead in America I'm telling you the
actual data says nine out of 10
millionaires are first generation
Rich that's it's such it's so counter
counterintuitive it's so
counternarrative both both
counternarrative it's not
counterintuitive not counterintuitive
counternarrative at at the macro level
at the you just can't get ahead anymore
and then at the micro level it's all
coming down it's all coming down it's
all coming down it's just not yeah yeah
it might be but it doesn't look I mean
everybody's having the best year of
their life man it's wild $100 a month
invested from age 25 to age 65 at 12% in
a good mutual fund and the stock market
is averaged
11.6 for 80 years okay but so you know
$100 a month invested from age 25 to age
65 1,
$176,000
$100 that's with no match that that's
with you know no magic and Tick Tock
mirrors to buy nothing down real estate
that you can't afford or shirts t-shirts
on for on on four
payments
yeah that's true yeah there's no
payments involved in that uh but people
can't find $100 you know and uh and the
reason is I got a $750 truck payment and
the reason is they got a student loan
that during the last three years when
there's been no interest they paid
nothing on it and and come Sunday Bloody
Sunday here we go man man uh I mean it's
uh this coming Sunday is the when the
student loans start back October one
baby it's here life is real so we're
going to send a team to uh Washington DC
yeah and do some man on- the street
stuff Monday because that's uh when the
student loans have started back the
government might also shut down by then
cuz the children and the sandbox
throwing crayons at each
other gosh Billy kicked sand in my eyes
he's a republican I don't like Dan he's
a Democrat it's my it's my my sand
castle I want to put $2 billion doar in
for uh Rat research in into the budget
and we keep voting for these and if you
don't do that then we're going to shut
down the government you know so you know
what it would be kind of cool if they
solve some morons dodgeball you voted
them in I voted them in it's our
freaking fault we we do this to
ourselves man I don't know one person
that's like man bang up job bang up job
anybody's doing I think you guys are
just amazing the efficiency by which you
govern in did you see that thing that
Warren Buffett said it's like amazing
when he said I could solve the the
deficit tomorrow yep you're all fired
yeah well or you don't you get zero pay
until you get the budget balanced oh by
the way I saw that um all the federal
employees will lose their paychecks when
they shut the government down but not
the uh Congress congress not the
Congress nope
nope uh we vote ourselves an exemption
because we're incompetent that puts this
hour of the Ramsey Show in the books
we'll be back with you before you know
it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus hey it's Dr John delone if you
like what you heard in this episode and
want to know more about getting started
on the ramsy baby steps go to ramsy
solutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's Ramy
solutions.com and click get
started